welcome back to another edition of The
Gadget Lab show I'm Michael colori I'm
Nathan olivo does Giles coming up later
we're going to take a look at a couple
of inexpensive synthesizers but first
taken as a new phone show us what you
got this is the HTC droid incredible 4G
LTE exclusive to verizon Wow say that
eight times fast and it's yours I can
long names and smartphones why does this
keep happening I don't know nonetheless
this is a follow-up to the droid
incredible and then droid incredible too
but it's an HTC phone right it is an HTC
phone and really this is the only new
HTC handset for verizon so far this year
I think it's the newest thing since what
I could put the Thunderbolt from last
year yeah maybe I don't know so but
verizon toy skipped out on HTC's awesome
one series and this is what they got hmm
so um tell us a little bit about it it's
small i notice it is small which i
actually like because there are so many
android phones that are going four and a
half inches 4.8 i think on samsung
galaxy s3 5.3 inches ya know which you
know who likes that but anyways um so
yeah you have 4 inch screen here and
with a 960 x 540 resolution okay so it's
not really an HD screen phone what I
kind of don't like but the four-inch
screen is nice actually the glass on the
front of the display here is about the
same size as an iphone Wow yeah so if
you held up your iPhone to this it like
fits right there and then you still have
like some external body around it's kind
of cool so there I think there still is
something to be said about this about
this form factor you know that's the
smaller those particularly because
that's one of the things that like
Android device makers they look at any
hundred space and they think well
there's a great way we can beat apples
will just make a device to the bigger
screen personally I have a hard time
with phones where I can't comfortably
reach anywhere on the screen with one
thumb yeah and this you can reach
anywhere you want with one thumb you can
use it easily with one hand when you get
to the galaxy s3 or the HTC One X it's
just a pain in the butt to do that so
any chance that things going to get
lean on it anytime soon um you know I'm
not sure it is an Ice Cream Sandwich
phone it's running HTC Sense for which
is really nice it's one of the better
alternatives i greased long Android out
there give you I like it yeah how long
it'll take HTC to catch up to jelly bean
I'm not sure hopefully sooner rather
than later but it you know this is a
good operating system also it's got the
red trim yep that's four beats beats
audio does it come with Beats headphones
it does not come with Beats headphones
it does come with a beats logo on the
back and their beats technology built-in
so it just makes the music sound louder
I wouldn't say necessarily better but
yeah that's HTC's you know
differentiating future flash gimmick
depending on how you look at it yeah
it's a gimmick but it's 200 bucks and
with a mail-in rebate of 150 yeah it
goes down to 150 after fifty to fifty
dollar mail-in rebate so it's one
hundred and fifty dollars so that's a
you know I guess a little bit cheaper
than and if you like a smaller phone
it's probably good choice yeah it
doesn't seem like it's too bad of a deal
will have a full review up on wired.com
/ reviews
alright Robbie's here hi we've got a
couple of cool toys to show you these
are some synthesizers some little tiny
synthesizers from the company Korg who
is famous for making giant synthesizers
and also things like chaos pads and some
DJ equipment but these are little ribbon
since there are about fifty dollars each
this is the korg monotron duo and this
is the monotron delay so you control it
by you know you control the pitch by
picking a place on this ribbon where you
put your finger this one's called the
duo because it has two oscillators you
can control them with the little knobs
on the front and then it also has a
filter frequency filter that you can
adjust the filtration of the oscillation
that comes basically the same except
it's got what delay this one has the
delay so you can it lights up if I don't
you can see it but the lights at the
rate of repeat and then if you can also
adjust the delay the time and the
feedback so if you have a lot of
feedback the delay will last for ever
forever it really does it goes on and on
so I think the important thing to note
about these is that you can buy
smartphone apps you can buy tablet apps
for you know one-fifth the costs
one-tenth the cost that make noises and
do a lot more than these but there is
something to be said for having a little
piece of groovy hardware when you're
playing live or when you're composing
music when you're adding sounds the
tactile feel of being able to reach over
and touch the knobs kind of adds a lot
to the experience yeah I actually have a
lot of those apps and I we have tried to
use them in my band playing live and
without the actual knobs and buttons
it's just not the same that the time it
always seems a little bit be a little
bit off and it and you're using a phone
and it's very weird you get text
messages from your way oh yeah yeah
these on the other hand these are it's
just it's a really low entry I played
with this one for five minutes and then
I ran in bought one yeah I have I
actually bought this after playing with
it for five minutes and it's awesome
when you're using it but
kind of annoying it's kind of annoying
for everyone else so how'd you get used
to it as with any electronic toy the the
key is taste to plea tastefully right
yes so we're going to do like a little
Marian McPartland NPR piano jazz binion
root beer too let's play something
together